CBS News senior national security
contributor Michael Morell was former
acting and deputy director of the CIA he
joins us from Washington Michael good
morning thanks for being here we're
getting sort of some conflicting
information about this attack first the
Supreme Leader of Iran said it's not
over the foreign minister said Iran took
and concluded proportionate measures
there's also some issue of how effective
this attack actually has been what do we
know at this point do you think so
Anthony I think we have to divide this
into the overt war between the two of us
are killing of Qasem Soleimani their
response last night and the covert war I
think the over war from the Iranian
perspective is over
I think direct attacks from Iran on
American forces is over for now
depending on what the President does
I think what's not over is the covert
war and I still think that down the road
we will see an Iranian terrorist attack
against the senior officials so I think
you can you can parse their language
into those two buckets overt covert
Michael conflicting information - about
the casualties US officials say no
casualties Elizabeth just reported in
Iran they're saying 80 were killed 200
injured who do we believe so I'm sure
there were no casualties I'm sure we
would be hearing because we we would be
hearing from the US military if there
were casualties no doubt about it and I
would believe what they were telling us
I think what we see in Iran is them
saying we hit back and we hit hard and
there were casualties and that allows
them to de-escalate so I think they're
sending us a message here that that in
terms of direct attacks this is done for
now but still as as David Martin pointed
out it really depends on what we do next
and what the president decides to do in
response so on that question Michael
over the weekend the president tweeted
if Iran attacks an American base or any
American we will be sending some of our
brand-new beautiful equipment their way
he means missiles that would appear
without hesitation so this was a base
with Americans in it does it rise to the
level of the
that the president spelled out would
yield a response so it does it fits it
fits his red line but his tweet last
night was suggested that maybe he wants
to deescalate here so we'll see this
morning you know what he has to say to
the this morning will be incredibly
important as to the next steps we do
have an opportunity to de-escalate we
have an opportunity for the president to
say they threw their best punch at us
and you know it we took it without any
casualties so there's an opportunity
here for both sides to de-escalate there
are reports of a dozen missiles being
fired to a layperson that sounds like a
lot is it and it's not and was it
intentionally that you think that there
were no casualties where they directed
them so the small number of missiles is
very interesting to me that the Iranians
have thousands of missiles so the fact
that they only did a dozen signals to me
that that they wanted to be proportional
here that they wanted to send a message
that they don't want to escalate in
terms of the precision of missiles Iran
has all sorts of missiles summer precise
some aren't until we know exactly what
kind of missiles they shot I don't think
we can answer the question about whether
they deliberately tried to miss
buildings and housing sites etc Michael
as as David Martin pointed out I mean we
attacked Soleimani they attacked the
base that launched the attack and sold
the money he's as David said you could
call it even at this point what advice
do you think the cabinet is giving
President Trump at this point so I would
hope that they're giving him the advice
that this is an opportunity to step back
from the precipice of war let's not
let's not retaliate let's call it even
and let's actually look for an
opportunity through an intermediary to
say to the Iranians look we came very
close to war here maybe it's time to sit
down and negotiate what our future
relationship is going to look like
that's what I would try to do all right
thank you very much Michael Morell I
know we'll be talking to you in the days
to come
you